[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo América
de Francia 24 Daniela Blandón nos
acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo Dani
bienvenida Qué bueno tener vamos a
hablar este Crónica especial de economía
de las tasas de interés por qué Porque
Estados Unidos volvió a subir
agresivamente en los tipos de las tasas
de esta semana y también hicieron muchos
otros bancos centrales Hola Raúl pues
mire la manera más ortodoxa que tenemos
o que tienen mejor los bancos centrales
para frenar una inflación galopante es
subiendo las tasas de interés y
viceversa ejemplo en pandemia los bancos
centrales del mundo redujeron al máximo
sus tipos de esta manera la gente
compraba más y se endeudaba y las
empresas podían apalancarse más barato
todo esto para reactivar la economía
pero una vez inició la Guerra en Ucrania
que se sumó a una crisis de contenedores
los precios de la canasta familiar se
dispararon y la estrategia de los bancos
centrales cambió drásticamente ahora
decidieron empezar a subir las tasas Qué
efecto tiene esto para los bolsillos lo
consultamos con el experto Dani en la
calle y esto nos dijo
la época de las tasas Ultra bajas yo
creo que ha acabado es una época que
hemos vivido por circunstancias
excepcionales tras la crisis financiera
y después con el covid pero yo creo que
eso se ha acabado obviamente pues las
personas que tengan sus ahorros en
depósitos van a recibir una remuneración
por esos depósitos las personas que
tengan deudas por supuesto van a ver que
el coste de la deuda sube si tienen
deudas a tipo variable a tasa variable
aunque las subidas de tipos Pues no son
algo que nos guste a mucha gente
es cierto que el objetivo de reducir la
inflación es mucho más importante porque
si la inflación se mantiene elevada
durante mucho tiempo
el impacto negativo en la economía es
mucho mayor es decir las subidas de
tipos son un pequeño daño como cuando
nos ponen una inyección una hace un poco
de daño pero la inflación que es una
grave enfermedad hace mucho más daño sin
embargo Dani hay bancos que no creen en
esta estrategia de aumentar las tasas
son muy pocos en el mundo Raúl pero los
hay el caso más representativo de los
que se salen del libreto es Turquía hoy
los precios Son 80% más altos que hace
un año en este país y sin embargo el
presidente
ha venido navegando en dirección opuesta
al resto del mundo y promoviendo
recortes masivos en los intereses Aunque
el Banco Central se supone es
independiente en Turquía no lo es tanto
el más reciente recorte ocurrido el
jueves llegó a la lira a mínimos
históricos otro país que está bajando
las tasas es Rusia y hay otros que lo
que hacen es mantenerlas como China y
Japón y ahora Brasil que después de
subirlas por 12 meses seguidos ya
determinó que es hora de dejarlas
quietas mientras que son mayoría los que
solamente esta semana han decidido
incrementarla le hablo de Noruega de
Indonesia de Taiwán de Argentina entre
muchos otros países y esto Dani ha hecho
que a Europa entonces llegue el fin de
las tasas negativas este fue un
experimento Raúl de más de una década y
termino esta semana cuando las tasas de
interés en Suiza volvieron a terreno
positivo lanzada desde la recesión de
2008 y 2009 Esta es una política de
tasas negativas que puso patas arriba al
modelo comercial estándar de dinero
entonces los bancos tenían que pagar una
tarifa para estacionar su efectivo en
los bancos centrales y algunos
propietarios se encontraron hipotecas
Que inclusive les pagaban intereses pero
ahora los bancos centrales se han
propuesto abandonar ese ejercicio en
Europa está volviendo a emerger un
fenómeno que aunque todavía es
incipiente si está sucediendo Y es que
la gente está volviendo a recibir
intereses por guardar dinero en este en
estos bancos nuestro invitado nos lo
explica
en Europa el efecto de este tipo de
subidas todavía no es suficiente como
para generar un movimiento agresivo de
capitales hacia
hacia el mecanismo de protección o
mecanismos de inversión pues como los
cdts verdad yo creo que la situación es
diferente Y bueno pues de momento lo que
podemos decir es que en Europa Sí hay un
factor importante gran parte del ahorro
de las familias está en depósitos los
depósitos daban rentabilidad negativa y
ahora empieza a ver lo que se llama una
guerra de depósitos en la que los bancos
empiezan a ofrecer
cantidades modestas pero todavía pero ya
positivas por que los ciudadanos
depositen su dinero en el banco pero
todavía ninguno de perfectos es
preocupante la demanda de crédito sigue
siendo elevada y las condiciones de
crédito siguen siendo amplias y de esta
manera Dani llegamos al final de este
bloque económico por ahora nos vemos el
lunes con más